[Music]
[Applause]
I think I'm already painting a message about standing on the stage
[Music] I
can't imagine it from a small body.
I think that's already a message
[Applause]
nan Jie
[Music]
Boo Boo polar Earth
is written by Vove Asao bjorn my name Kana
I say guitar, vocals and kin mode
Order Mizumaru I was a good issue with vocals I will
compose the engine type in the game
We are twins and 3 girls are fair in the wood garden part of high school
and courage is in college I invited
and became chai  Tay
[Applause]
od Complex Good
body music
Myr g
Pairis Amin pse Lovely Aizu
pc see
aok Jie
Hawaii is the top person and there is only one cute one in Japan
7  It's the biggest compliment book for women, and on the contrary, the range of cuteness is amazing as I said earlier. In
Japan, it's narrow.
It's
said that people with white skin are beautiful in Japan, so
I think it's strange to say that people with white skin once a week or everyone else are ugly, but
we were originally  There was another complex
, and when I was a student, I was worried about each of them, and when I was a student, I thought that each other's compex was the charm of the outs.
The number of copies is only three-way opening, and it's such a wonderful point of Chan.
[Music]
me
par Since I was born as a human
being  I wanted to make everything cute, so there is
also the word cute, so I
made it because I wanted to say that there is something cute in the first place,
not just in Japan, but maybe the complex.
I want to change the cute values of the world that I thought when I came to the conversation because it is common to all over the world [Musi
] [Appl
use] [Musi
] se e
Musi
] [Beat
Hand]
[Music]